قد يرغب عشاق الأفعوانية في الاستعداد
لهذه القصة التالية، حيث
اضطر متنزه في ولاية كارولينا الشمالية إلى
إغلاق إحدى ألعابه يوم الجمعة بعد
العثور على صدع كبير في
عمود دعم فولاذي، وقال جيريمي واجنر لشبكة CNN إنه
كان يزور متنزه كارويندز الترفيهي
في شارلوت عندما  لقد لاحظ
صدعًا،
بدأ في التقاط مقطع فيديو لـ
Fury 325 والذي يُظهر العمود
يتحرك قليلاً من مكانه هناك، ورأى أنه
عندما يمر الركاب، يقول إنه نبه
الموظفين وإدارة الإطفاء في شارلوت
بشأن المشكلة، كما قال كارويندز في
رسالة بالبريد الإلكتروني إلى CNN
الذي تعطل، يقوم فريق صيانة الأجزاء
بإجراء فحص شامل
وستظل الرحلة مغلقة حتى يتم
الانتهاء من الإصلاحات، يأخذ الجاذبية
الدراجين إلى ارتفاع
325 قدمًا ويصل إلى 95 ميلاً في الساعة